[Music]
there are literally hundreds of
different api's available under the
Google umbrella things like Drive
calendar Google cloud platform maps and
YouTube just to name a few but when you
log in a user on firebase you only get
access to a limited set of read-only
data like their Google+ profile in
today's video you'll learn how to work
with the Google Calendar API on the
behalf of a user but more importantly
you'll learn how to expand the scope of
firebase auth to work with virtually any
other Google API if you're new here like
and subscribe and there will be a
one-of-a-kind shirt giveaway with this
video all you have to do is leave a
comment below letting me know which
Google API you want to see covered next
and I'll randomly pick a winner via
livestream tomorrow let's start things
off by taking a look at what we're
actually building today it's currently
Saturday night and I don't have anything
additional on my calendar for today but
if we skip ahead to Monday you'll see
that I have a handful of appointments
the goal of this lesson is for you to be
able to log in a user with firebase and
then programmatically update or read
items in the calendar the inspiration
for this video comes from a real-life
tour operator based in New York City
after they sign up they need to build
out a complex itinerary for their trip
now there's actually a couple different
ways you can go about this but I'm going
to show you the approach that I think is
most developer friendly and flexible as
you can see here when we log in it looks
exactly like we're logging in with
firebase and the Google auth provider
but that's actually not what happened
instead we use the Google services
JavaScript library to sign in that gave
us a JSON web token that we could then
pass off to firebase to login as a
firebase user the reason we do this is
because we're going to use the Google
services library to make API requests to
the calendar API and it will
automatically manage our access tokens
so we can do everything from the
front-end then once we're logged in we
can retrieve this user it's Google
Calendar by simply making a call to that
API so the data we're looking at here in
the UI are actual events from my Google
Calendar in addition to reading the data
we can also create update and delete
data for example if I click this add
event button it's sending an insert
request to the API and adds a new item
to my calendar so now I know to stop
working and have some fun about an hour
from now but first we need to write some
code
I'm working from an angular app and
assuming that you have angularfire
installed but even if you're working
with a different framework that process
is still very similar the only thing we
need is firebase auth we don't need to
save anything in our back-end database
or do anything with cloud functions the
next thing we'll need to do is set up a
script to initialize the Google API
client instead of using the angular HTTP
client we'll use the Google API client
which will automatically handle all the
access token stuff for us and the script
is pretty lightweight if you're worried
about performance the next thing we'll
do is set up an authentication service
that will log in the user and make
requests to the API inside the service
will import angularfire
auth and also off from the main firebase
SDK then we'll need to declare a global
variable for gappy or Google API it is
possible to strong type this and I'll
show you how in the main article but
their community maintain types and I
think they're screwed up for Google
Calendar so I'm going to just leave them
out all together for this video so
you'll want to use the Google Calendar
API reference as the main source of
truth for your documentation the next
thing we'll do in our service is set up
a user property which is an observable
of the firebase user and we'll also
declare the calendar items that we want
to use in the UI here which is an array
of objects from there we can inject
angularfire
auth in the constructor this is where we
will initialize gapi and then we'll
define our user as the angularfire off
state I'm going to write a net client as
its own method and the first thing that
you do is you initialize or load the
main client library then you'll
initialize the client libraries that you
want to use which in our case it will be
authentication version 2 and Google
Calendar version 3 this is the point
where we'll set up our credentials and
our scopes for the api's that we want to
use the first value is the API key which
we can find directly in the firebase
console if you go to project settings
then the second value is your OAuth
client ID which you can find in a
variety of places but you'll want to go
to the Google cloud platform console for
this one you can go to the console and
then find it under the API is and
services tab it's going to be your web
oo-ahh
- client ID when you see that you'll
want to go ahead and click on it which
will take you to this page and you'll
want to update the
authorized JavaScript origins to
localhost 4200 or whatever local port
you're working on the third argument is
an array of Discovery docks there are so
many different api's at Google that they
can't all be described in a single
package so you pass on the Discovery
docks for the api's that you want to use
in our case we're using version 3 of
Google Calendar and lastly you pass in
the Scopes that you want the user to
grant permission to every API has
different levels of permission that the
user can grant access to you in our case
here we want to fully manage the
calendar so we're gonna ask for the full
calendar scope but you should only
request permission for the things that
you actually need so if you only needed
to read the items you should just
request read-only access so that will
initialize gappy in our project and
manage the access tokens for us so we
can easily make requests to this API
when the user is authenticated the last
thing we'll need to do with the
initialization is load in calendar
version 3 and then we can console.log
when it's ready if you've worked with
Google OAuth and firebase you're
probably used to write in your OAuth
code with just one or two lines of code
unfortunately we're going to need to
increase that code to about five lines
instead of using firebase to login
initially we'll call gapi off to get
auth instance and then we'll say await
Google auth sign-in this is pretty much
identical to doing sign-in with pop-up
with the firebase SDK it creates a JSON
web token that logs the user into the
client app which we can then access by
saying get off response dot ID token at
this point the users logged into Google
but they're not logged in to firebase
firebase has a way to sign in manually
when you already have a JSON web token
which we can do by calling Google auth
provider dot credential and pass in that
token then we can use that to sign the
user in to firebase by calling
angularfire auth sign in and retrieve
data with credential and pass in the
credential in the main article I'll show
you an alternate approach where you log
the user into firebase first and then
set up the Scopes from there but then
you have to manage your own tokens
manually which tends to be a lot more
work overall from here we'll go ahead
and add a logout method really quick and
now we're ready to start making API
calls to Google Calendar gappiya is
promise based so we can set this up as
an async function and we'll call gapi
client calendar
events dot lists and again because we
don't have the strong type we'll have to
look at the API Docs manually but we're
really just looking at a handful of
arguments here to get the items from the
calendar that we want so here we're
requesting the primary calendar all
events that start in the future and
we'll order them by start time I'd
recommend console logging the response
so you can see what the actual data
payload looks like in this case the
actual calendar items we want to show in
the UI are found on events dot result
items so once the user is logged in all
they have to do is trigger this get
calendar method and that will return the
events from their calendar because we
requested the full calendar scope we
have full credit Allender before I write
this method I'm first going to set up a
helper function called hours from now
that takes a number as its argument and
then returns the number of hours in the
future as an ISO string you probably
don't need it but I'm just using it to
make our code a little bit more readable
to add a new event will call gap e
client calendar events insert and then
we have a whole bunch of different
options that we can use here to format
the actual calendar event it will go on
the primary calendar and then we'll have
a start object that has a date time and
then also a time zone and then of course
an end time and lastly we'll add a
summary and a description to give it
some interesting content then as a final
touch whenever we insert an event will
then retrieve our calendar events again
which resets them on the service so
it'll look like the event updates in
real time on our UI so that takes care
of all the hard work now let's go into
our app component and put this service
to use the first thing I want to do is
inject the awe service in that component
constructor and you'll actually want to
make it a public property even though it
says private here in the source code
from here it's just a matter of adding a
little bit of markup to show our user
and the calendar items we can unwrap the
user observable by doing ng if followed
by auth dot user async and then we'll
set it as a template variable called
user that provides their Google+
information like the photo URL and their
display name all the other methods can
be treated as event handlers so we'll
just let the user click buttons to log
in and make calls to their Google
Calendar API and lastly our calendar
items are an array on the service so we
can loop over those with ng
four and they're already unwrapped so we
don't need to use the async pipe here
and that will give you a whole bunch of
data for each item which you can inspect
in the console if you follow it along
with the code you should see a response
object in the console it's all the data
that's returned from the Google
calendars API including the items upon
that user's calendar so now you know how
to get ahold of a Google Calendar that's
owned by a firebase user but more
importantly you know how to use the
Google API client library to access all
of the hundreds of different API is
offered by Google I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you're serious about building a
product consider becoming a pro member
at angular firebase com you'll get
unlimited access to all premium content
which includes multiple full courses and
a full length book as well as one on one
project support to help you get your app
built and shipped faster thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you soon